zendaya and fifth Harmony's Lauren hurry
G speak out at the 2017 Teen Choice
Awards in the wake of the violence in
Charlottesville on Saturday white
nationalist gathered in Charlottesville
Virginia for a unite the right March
where they were met by counter
protesters things took a violent turn
when a car plowed into the crowd leaving
one dead and dozens injured on Sunday
when zendaya accepted the surfboard for
choice summer movie actress at the TCAs
she used the opportunity to remind her
fans about their power to affect change
with all the injustice and the hatred
and everything that is happy not only in
the world but in our country right now I
need four young people I need you guys
to be educated I need you to listen I
need you to pay attention
[Applause]
go ahead and understand you have a voice
and it is okay to use it when you see
something bad
this harmony also used their platform to
spread a positive message in light of
recent events we just wanted to say to
all of the young ones at home watching
no matter who you are where you come
from or what you look like you are
beautiful and you are important so keep
spreading love and positivity all right
[Music]